let's do a full overview of Scientology
it's ideas how it operates how it wields
its power and influence and let's start
at the very Basics what is Scientology
Scientology is a belief system
created by lren Hubbard
that does fundamentally believe that we
are all Immortal Spiritual Beings
called thetans
that we have
native god-like potential
that there is nothing more powerful in
the universe than a thetan like so
Godlike is you know quite literal here
and that through various
decisions things have made they have
fallen away from their native god-like
power
two uh fallen down to a state where most
things aren't even aware that they are
thetans aren't even aware that they ever
have lived before or have these powers
and that things are now in a state where
they're trapped in bodies trapped here
on Earth uh trapped in this prison of a
physical Universe trapped on this prison
of a planet
and that only Scientology can restore
ethane to its native state are these
multiple beings like is there one Satan
inside of me that's trapped in this
prison well the thing would be you
the thing would be me the thetan is you
but I'm presumably Limited in some
fundamental way so this statement that
is me is is limited so there's like
eight billion satans on the planet
there's one primary thing in animating
each body
later in Scientology you learn there's
actually like tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of like sick
unconscious half dead face and stuck to
you that are now an additional cause of
problems for you sure but fundamentally
at the lower levels
the non-confidential levels there's just
one thing per body
well I mean it's an interesting idea I
just would like to kind of explore
the philosophy of that so there's a
being that's all powerful that's
immortal
and its projectionist manifestation on
this Earth is
fundamentally Limited and you're trying
to uh the process of Scientology is the
process of letting go of those
limitations
you know that's an interesting idea I
mean a lot of religions have this kind
of idea that there's uh not just
religions but like we have the capacity
as human beings to do to achieve
greatness in all kinds of ways yeah and
that's the question we have with our
cognitive abilities we start with the
embryo and build up and into this
organism and like this world of
opportunities before us what are we
capable of and the idea that we're
capable of almost anything is a really
powerful one and there's a lot of
religions there's a lot of philosophies
there's a lot of advice self-help that
kind of explores those ideas and so in
it seems like with Scientology this the
application of these religious
philosophy means that there's we're
limited and we'll have to break the
through those limitations and there's a
process to break through those
limitations that would be correct so
what can make it challenging to
adequately and completely describe
Scientology in the beginning is what
scientologists believe actually changes
as they progress
further into or further up in
Scientology
so
um the explanation is I've given it is
pretty consistent with what you would
get at the lowest levels right
urethane I'm a thetan everyone's a
thetan
and we have a reactive mind
I'll run Hubbard would say the reactive
mind is a collection of uh these
recordings mental recordings of any
moments of pain and unconsciousness
you've ever had in your life it's like
the subconscious mind
uh it's always recording in moments of
pain and unconsciousness and that these
are called uh these recordings are Ron
Hubbard called them engrams now when now
Ron Hubbard first wrote Dianetics in
1950 this was before Scientology came
along a couple years later right so in
1950 when you wrote Dianetics
it wasn't a spiritual Endeavor it was
supposed to be a mental health a science
of Mental Health
so
as of that time the earliest engram you
could have was the incident of birth
being born was an engram
and technically in Dianetics they said
you could have prenatal engrams like
when you're still in the womb but there
was no concept of past lives as of 1950
version of Dianetics right
and so the idea there was that
uh the reactive mind is essentially a
stimulus response mechanism
created through Evolution millions of
years ago to protect the individual from
things that would harm them in other
words things that would bring about pain
and unconsciousness so you have these
recordings of things that hurt you
created pain and unconsciousness and in
present time these things will react
upon you in a way to cause you to avoid
similar things reacting upon you in a
subconscious unconscious way so the
reactive mind protects you
from the trauma that is inside your
subconscious mind yes and the idea is
we've now as human beings evolve to a
state where it no longer serves us
beneficially it only serves us
negatively
this was Harvard's Theory and he says
you can get rid of these engrams by you
know basically recalling them and going
over them again and again using
Dianetics auditing therapy and if you
get back to the moment of birth and
erase the earliest engram all the other
subsequent engrams on the Chain would
vanish oh nice so there's a change
earlier similar earlier similar earlier
similar early similar okay
so that gives you a pretty good
understanding of how elrond Hubbard
thought of the mind because that carries
on has applicability later on in
Scientology I mean that's a pretty
powerful model of the mind I mean Freud
had similar conceptions that a lot of
our traumas are grounded in
sort of uh
poor formulation of sexuality or
imperfect formulation of sexuality no
childhood something like this and then
we're trying to figure out the puzzle
whatever we formed in early childhood
right and it's similar similar kind of
it is similar that's probably what
Hubbard took it from
um in the early days of Dianetics before
he decided Psychiatry was evil uh he
actually credited Sigmund Freud with
some of the shoulders he was standing on
in writing Dianetics so the so he still
admired Psychiatry at that time so
that's an interesting moment of
Dianetics so what else you mentioned
Dynex auditing was there too so if we
just before Scientology what what are
the ideas that formed what we know as
Dianetics as I've just described that is
the fundamental at least that is pretty
much the nuts and bolts of dinetics was
it applied was it applied often oh yeah
no that's what Dynex in the early days
was all about was just auditing auditing
is the process of the one-on-one
counseling recall a moment of pain and
unconsciousness run through the engram
over and over and over again find
something earlier Simo that is dianetics
auditing one of the main things that
changed with Scientology is that birth
or prenatal ingrams were no longer the
earliest engrams on the Chain yeah the
idea is you have to get the earliest
engram on the chain for the later ones
to blow which is a race
and so but all of a sudden now with the
uh addition of an immortal spiritual
being into the equation well now the
earliest incident could be trillions of
years ago in other galaxies and
universes other universes so before the
origin of this universe yes is there a
model of physics integrated in any of
this no
the model is you have the physical
universe
and then above that you have the Theta
universe so we use the word thing
earlier so in Scientology let's use word
Theta
I don't know theta's just basically
thetan power Satan's collectively
so Hubbard would say you have the Theta
Universe which is senior to the physical
universe and creates the physical
universe and remember I said I said
native god-like potentials so we're not
talking about the God who created the
Earth we're just like scientologists
don't believe in a God but we'll get
into that later
uh we're talking about just creating
universes like just think like Matrix
like just when I say creating Universe
essentially just creating different
things simulations
but it sounds like a little bit more
like the ideas of Plato which is there's
these platonic forms there's abstract
forms that are
bigger more General than our particular
reality here and those forms are used to
construct the reality well I grew up in
a cult so I'm not familiar with the
works of Plato
[Laughter]
you can't use that as an excuse for
everything
I would like to you know non-jokingly
yeah Steel Man the case because a lot of
philosophies a lot of religions a lot
even scientific endeavors
are a little bit full of uh uncertainty
you can call it [__] but they're
you're on on sturdy ground because we're
surrounded by mystery and you have to
take these ideas
somewhat seriously and see where those
ideas go wrong this happens with
Communism this happens with capitalism
these ideas sound beautiful in their
ideal forms and then they somehow go
wrong and some go more wrong than others
and so I don't think sort of it's easy
to
sort of caricature and make fun of the
ideas I think if we take them seriously
you'll start to understand like when
you're in it it was serious uh it can be
very convincing it's you know the the
devil is going to be a charismatic
person he's not going to be a caricature
of ridiculous person so that that helps
us understand which ideas
uh will sound appealing but will become
dangerous I totally agree in fact it's
one of the
thrusts uh I have on my channel is
wanting to talk about scientology in a
way that would actually resonate with
current scientologists yeah not just
resonate with former scientologists I
want people who are still in to be able
to hear how I talk about it and go wow
he's being really fair and really
accurate he's not just a hater you know
what I mean if you look at the you know
let's take one of the worst places on
Earth is North Korea uh you have Kim
Jong-un and the reality is there's a lot
of citizens of that nation that deeply
love
the leader
because they've grew up in that way and
you I mean through fear through all
kinds of manipulation through propaganda
and so on they're not allowed to love
members of their own family they're not
allowed to have romantic love they're
only allowed to have love for the leader
and to reach those people you have to
empathize with the fact that in their
eyes in some sense this is a great man
this is a god a Messianic figure you
can't just make fun of
the Ridiculousness of the situation that
this this pudgy person Waltzing around
creating propaganda like how is this a
funny haircut with a funny haircut like
it's so easy and Hitler too to make fun
of to make a caricature of the person
but this is a real person a real person
that influenced the minds of millions of
people in the case of Hitler uh you know
tens of millions of people and and
created a huge amount of suffering not
because of
um the caricature version but because he
was a charismatic leader he was somebody
that people deeply deeply loved and that
just over time I mean with uh the abuse
of any kind of ideology this this
happens over and over and so yeah it's
it's interesting because
Scientology is so close to the
uh to to the core of what is America
because so many Americans are involved
with it so it's interesting to study the
the Beauty and the power of the ideas
that underlie it and where things go
wrong yeah
and I'll just say it's interesting to
know you would never get a
representative of the Church of
Scientology to sit down and have a
conversation with you and even be as
fair and accurate about scientology as
I'm going to be which is which is
noteworthy do you honestly deeply
believe that's the case there's not
going to be a high level official that
would sit down for a conversation
no I disagree with you I hope you're
right because I think that given the
current dynamics of what's Happening
I think in order to say from their
perspective in order to save the Church
of Scientology they have to uh be
transparent and authentic basically
steal men their case but better you
would think so
well we'll talk about the other ways you
could do that which is the manipulation
to propaganda through control media and
all that kind of stuff they paint
themselves into a corner of not being
able to send a representative out into
the world to speak honestly about it
because you're literally not allowed to
so when faced you know if you're just
sitting down with an entertainment
journalist a representative might be
able to fudge their way through an
interview but sitting down for a long
Format Interview with someone who is
going to ask them about Xenu and the
body fatens and Leah Remini and Lisa
McPherson that's a no-go zone so so I'm
representing why it will never happen
but [__] I would I would tune in for
that interview I mean I hope you do get
some way you don't think David
miscaviors sit down for an interview
I would love to be wrong you know in
general journalists in these kinds of
situations can be
um
can attack
in a way that doesn't empathize and
doesn't come from a place of deep
knowledge and understanding and I think
it's possible to have serious
conversations with people like that in
an empathetic way but it's also in a
challenging way I think there's a huge
amount of trust required and obviously
for us a very secretive organization the
amount of trust yes might be too much
required anyone over there if they've
done their homework knows you're going
to be as Fair as anyone in the world is
going to be
and yet they're simply things they're
not allowed to talk about and they're
not even allowed to say I'm not allowed
to talk about it so that's a fundamental
part of the Church of Scientology is the
secrecy yeah
so that's where you're trained as you go
up through the ranks the secrecy secrecy
it's not even a matter of training it's
that there's an entire the entire upper
half of scientology's bridge is simply
confidential I mean and I never even did
those levels when I was in Scientology I
didn't learn what scientologists
actually believe on those upper levels
until after I get out of Scientology and
I was freaking born and raised in it
let's go there let's go to a personal
story so you've spent 30 years in
cytology yeah I was four years old when
my mom got in and then about seven years
ago I got out yeah and you're on what
YouTube channel now and you're an
educator so I was four years old when my
mom got introduced to Scientology and
she got in really fast really quick
um so but I was 12 years old when I was
taken out of school and started
officially full-time working for
Scientology
okay so
um in various capacities I worked for
them from the ages of 12 to the age of
26. yeah okay so and then I was 34 when
I officially parted ways with
Scientology uh which was really more
them officially parting ways with me but
we can get into all that later that's
just kind of how Scientology does it and
what do you do now in terms of
Scientology so now I run growing up in
Scientology the YouTube channel but what
I primarily do is I help run an
organization that helps people who are
escaping from Scientology I'm the vice
president of the aftermath Foundation
and we created the foundation after the
television show Leah Remini Scientology
in the aftermath
and there was such an outpouring of
support from non-scientologists all over
the world
what can we do to help people leave
Scientology that we decided to create a
foundation and it's been incredibly
successful we've helped people escape
from all regions and echelons of
Scientology we we've accomplished what
we've accomplished is far beyond what we
actually envisioned would be possible
it's been a huge success